تاخر الهجوم المضاد كثيرا ولكياب اسبابها
ربما اولا الغرب تردد في ارسال الاسلحه
الثقيله وثانيا
اصر على الصمود فيها لتخسر كياب الكثير من
الوقت القوات الروسيه حصلت على الوقت
اللازم لبناء دفاعات موثوقه لكن حادثه
واحده اعادت توزيع الاوراق في جبهه كانت
منسيه تفجير سد نوفا واين في خرسون
المدينه التي شهدت ما يعرف بالانسحاب
اللغز للقوات الروسيه تراجعت قبل الشتاء
الماضي لتتحصن وراء نهر دنيبر وموسكو
تحججت وقتها بتدمير جسري انطونوبسكي شريان
الحياه الوحيد بين خرسون وبقيه المقاطعه
الخطوه سمحت بانقاذ عشرين الف جنديا
الروسي كانوا معزولين في الجبهه الاخرى
ولا مجال لامدادهم لكن هذه كانت روايه
واحده للقصه روايه اخرى جاءت على اللس ان
لقد قمت باعلام شركائنا الاوروبيين اليوم
خلال اجتماع المجلس الاوروبي بخصوص الهجوم
الروسي المقبل
استعدوا روسيا لتدمير سد نوفا ومحطته
الكهرومائيه حسب المعلومات المتوفره لدينا
ويجب على كل العالم ان يعمل بكل قوه من
اجل منع حدوث هذا الهجوم الارهابي الروسي
تقدمت كييف عن بدء هجومها المضاد بينما
الكثير من الدلائل هناك تتحدث عن بدءه حيث
شنت اوكرانيا ضربات صاروخيه ومدفعيه
وبالمسيرات والعبوات الناسفه طالت عده
مناطق في غرب روسيا ودون باس بالاضافه
لهجمات بريه على عدد من النقاط الحدوديه
اما هنا فاعلنت وزاره دفاع موسكو عن بدء
تعزيز طال انتظاره لقوتها العسكريه مع
نهايه هذا العام يتمثل بجيش بري واخر جوي
وفيلق عسكري بالاضافه الى قوه ازوف
البحريه وخمس فرق وسته وعشرين لواء كما
يدور الحديث عن انشاء منطقتين عسكريتين في
كل من موسكو
الاوكراني
اتهم روسيا بمحاوله تفجير سد نوفا قليله
قبل انسحابها من مدينه خرسون وقتها نفى
قائد القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
السابقين الامر ورد التهمه لاوكرانيا
اشاره الى ان محطه نوفا تعرضت للقصف من
قبل كييف مرات عده بصواريخ هاي مارس
وبحسب سيرابيكيين كان الهدف اغراق مناطق
السيطره الروسيه واجبارها على مغادره غرب
خرسون وهو ما سيسمح للجيش الاوكراني من
عبور نهر النيفر دون قتال روسيا سحبت
بعدها بايام من غرب نهر النيفر سد النوبه
لم يدمر لكنه تعرض للاستهداف مرات كثيره
ولم تنقصه الا الضربه الاخيره التي افاضت
مياها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات